[Music]
I've been using Apple's Brand New Vision
Pro over the weekend and it's pretty
clear that it's an amazing product due
to all the attention that it's getting
and the higher than expected orders that
it received but the major problem is the
extremely high
$3,500 price tag I'm a tech reviewer and
I'm pretty sure I'm going to return this
headset and not because I don't enjoy it
I love it it's just the insane price so
in this video I'm going to share my
experience over the weekend including my
thoughts on the price as well as talk
about the lower cost vision air headset
which apple is actually working on right
now according to Mark German back last
year on October 15th Mark German within
his power on newsletter let us know that
there's actually going to be a lower
cost vision air model that's going to be
quite a lot cheaper than the one that we
have now and he did mention that back
then Apple actually shifted their staff
away from developing a standalone AR
glasses product towards working on the
lower cost headset German said that
apple is going to be potentially
dropping the eyesight and the M series
chip features in exchange for probably
an A series chip and order to lower the
cost now with those changes and probably
more like potentially reducing the
refresh rate of the displays or
potentially the quality German says that
they'll be able to lower the price down
to between $1,500 and
$2500 which is a pretty big range but
it's definitely more attainable than
$3,500 plus tax almost 4,000 bucks now
this of course sounds great but it is a
bit disappointing to get rid of the
eyesight feature because I've been using
it and it feels so nice to be at home
and feel like you're in the room with
your family you can see them you can
talk to them they can see your eyes you
can make eye contact and even here in
the office all three of us are sitting
there at our desks using our vision pros
at the same time and we can turn to each
other make eye contact so we can be more
productive and work on our videos but I
do like the idea of having a $1,500
vision air and I think that's awesome
just so that more people can get to
experience this or at least a taste of
what the actual Vision Pro is like and I
do think that it's going to be worth
buying the actual Vision Pro over the
vision air because it's going to have
more performance in terms of having the
better chips with potentially the higher
refresh rate resolution the eyesight and
other features that are going to make it
really worth spending the extra cash if
you're really invested and you can be
more productive with the Vision Pro like
right now I'm literally screen recording
this I think I am yep okay screen
recording is going and I'm using my
Vision Pro with the notes app open as my
teleprompter sitting in front of the
camera so it looks like my eyes are
looking at you hopefully I'm not sure if
the actual eyesight feature works with
just a camera and not a person I'm not
sure but it's so cool because I have my
music app open right here I can control
it I have an article here from Mac
Rumors talking about and I can add even
more if I want to so it's already making
me more productive just having my
teleprompter right here in front of me
and yes I did write all of these notes
and this script with the Vision Pro
mostly using the speech to text feature
which I found to be much quicker because
I could literally just say my thoughts
as my script instead of using the actual
onscreen keyboard which I found to be
pretty slow now Ben in her office he was
able to get his Mac keyboard to connect
to the Vision Pro and he's been able to
use it for his Vision Pro apps which for
me it's not working for some reason
maybe some software maybe I got it
updated or something but it's not
working to use my actual Mac but for him
it is which is really cool now jumping
back to the vision air leaks and when I
think that's going to come out I have a
feeling that it might take up to a year
and a half or maybe 2 years from now
maybe even WWDC
20206 for the new vision air to come out
just so that Apple can have a good solid
2 years worth of sales and hype and
excitement for the Vision Pro and really
get developers engaged in making more
awesome apps especially more games which
I feel right now are kind of lacking I
did play a couple of games over the
weekend like that one beat saer Style
music game which was really fun my wife
actually tried it out she had a blast I
was posting that on Twitter really fun I
also played chess and Battleship that
was truly awesome because you literally
can see it in front of you you can grab
the pieces move them or just look at
them with your eyes tap drag I've never
experienced gaming like this ever before
now in terms of what I think about the
$3,500 tag I think it's totally worth it
if you're going to be using this for
work or if you travel a lot and you
think you can make that money back
through your business or your work
whatever you do because it truly does
help you be more productive but if
you're in a position where you're in
debt and you're just trying to get this
for fun because you have fomo you're
seeing everybody online use it and it
looks so cool and you really want to buy
it honestly in that case I wouldn't
recommend it it because that price tag
is just such a huge pill to swallow and
you might find that you're not getting
your money's worth but for me now that
I've used it over the weekend and I've
been using it here in the office instead
of my regular Mac setup I can honestly
see myself using this dayt day at the
office instead of my Mac because you can
have so many screens open at once so
much information and all it takes is a
simple glance over you tap swipe turn
turn on your music look over to the
other one that's all it takes it's so
quick faster than you can do it on a Mac
it's just so productive and the best
part is that at the end of the day you
can literally take it home with you and
use it for entertainment research the
web Reddit and my favorite part is that
you can literally just get up and move
somewhere else you can grab your window
with you walk around set it somewhere
else like when my wife made me some
brownies with ice cream she asked me to
sit at the table so that the kids don't
end up going to the couch and eating
there I simply grabbed my window moved
it over to the end of the table it was a
truly amazing experience and other users
online have even shown themselves load
up their entire apartment with different
windows in different spots including a
Notes app right in front of the fridge
as a shopping list and everything stays
there perfectly in place as you walk
around which is basically the dream of
the future that so many people have had
for decades so with that said do I think
it's worth
$3,500 or should you just wait for the
leaked vision air that might be between,
1500 to 2500 well honestly now that I've
been using it for a couple of days it's
so much better in real life than what
everybody makes it look like online
which is already really cool and I'm
honestly getting very tempted to keep it
even though my initial plan was just to
test it out make videos with it and
return it because it's just so dang
expensive and I've noticed that with
each day that I test it out and use it
it's becoming more and more tempting
because my eyes are now getting used to
the displays I'm learning more about how
to use it properly and more productively
and it just keeps getting better and
better so maybe I'll have to sell some
of my other tech gadgets to make enough
money to account for the Vision Pro
because this is just so incredible even
right now as I'm filming the script and
seeing everything around me you just
can't experience this anywhere else so
with that said hopefully you enjoy this
video and my thoughts on the leaked
vision air and the pricing for the
Vision Pro if you enjoyed it leave a
comment down below definitely subscribe
above because we have a bunch of other
Vision Pro content coming definitely
watch one of those videos right there
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next
[Music]
video